today on stick to football we have
another great prospect interview for a
hunter Bryant the tight in from the
University of Washington we're gonna
talk about our fantasy rookie pics
because it's always fantasy football
time and answer your draft on draft
questions also we're recording this
Tuesday morning
tonight Connor and I are going to be the
guest commentators during the be our
goat simulations I honestly don't know
who we are commentating for though I
believe we have Chiefs Broncos which I
was the way the Elway mahomes matchup I
like sweet I'll have to pretend like I'm
not a Chiefs fan for the night but you
can know I would like you to be because
then I'll take the Broncos and we'll
make some stupid bet over it the Broncos
will win I do believe you can watch out
three of us Matt Val Connor Aube leach
reports YouTube right now or of course
listen where we get your podcast but you
guys Monday night they did four of these
simulation games and I tried I you know
everybody's working from home we got our
kids at home all the time tried to watch
some of these there were some massive
upsets in my opinion the Redskins beat
the Cowboys let's start there I think
the Cowboys were a sneaky favorite to
win this thing
no did not happen iki I I can't believe
that the Redskins I guess same on any
given Monday night of a party to report
Madden simulation game you just don't
know who's gonna win I bet a lot of
people that were betting money on this
and pretty upset because you'd have to
think that the Cowboys are gonna come
out victorious on this thing one of the
greatest franchises in all of the NFL
and they lose to the Redskins I think
part of the problem was Troy Aikman was
the third quarterback on the roster cuz
they let the fans vote on that part of
it who was the start I think it was
Roger Staubach as long as it wasn't Romo
he was second yeah that's right they
were saying he was second yeah and then
the Patriots beat the Dolphins and it
was like a Smackdown and I really
thought Dan Marino and you know duper at
wide receiver like that you know there
would be some talent in there they
should have just played the 72 dolphins
they that's they should have just made
them run out there one more time yeah
except with Dan Marino instead of greasy
yeah so Patriots win which I know makes
everyone here incredibly happy the
here's one didn't see this coming I
actually was talking smack on Twitter
before Jaguars call
like the Colts are going to kill
Jacksonville hey who's even on the
Jacksonville team well they're pretty
good actually and they beat the Colts
which shocked the Colts have Peyton
Manning not the Broncos the Colts too
and the Jags beat them which was a
gigantic surprise to me go Fred Taylor
though I mean any given Monday night any
given simulation no idea what's gonna
happen yeah I didn't think when you look
at it everybody assumed that Colts
offense would put up like 70 points a
game with how much talent they have it
every single skilled position and Peyton
Manning yeah turns out Peyton Manning
not mobile and that does affect you in
this game and then the final one
Panthers beat the Falcons so Michael
Vick is out of this thing now I believe
a single-elimination so Michael Vick is
out Cam Newton and the Panthers roll on
though if they would have used the 2004
simulator to do this no one would have
beat the Falcons but using that 20
version I guess I think the Chiefs are
gonna be scary in this now because Pat
mahomes in the way that he is in that
game I haven't played it a whole lot but
I know that Pat mahomes is dominant
almost as dominant as he is in real life
and men so I think the Chiefs are gonna
be scary I'll be eager to see what you
guys do with that tonight but the
Falcons being out again hi I thought
Michael Vick would just be too much but
apparently Luke Kuechly leading these
Panthers again is just too much on
defense the Falcons couldn't do any
pepper 'he's right low key good team
alright on to some real football news
here we got a we got a pretty big
offseason one from Mike Garrett folow
saying that when this isn't shocking
multiple teams are interested in Yannick
and gawk way guys let's just start it
here why is Jacksonville what's clearly
a fractured relationship holding on so
long here do you think that teams just
haven't PO need up what they probably
consider is a fair price of a first
rounder I do think that and I think it's
more than one not multiple first
rounders but I think you see me a first
rounder Plus this is something here a
lot of people talk about DeForest
Buckner and which is traded for 13
overall and he's a very good player but
I think we would all argue that a 25
year old edge rusher is more valuable
than a 25 year old defensive tackle
especially unless you're Aaron Donald
and so far in gaku I think we are seeing
Jacksonville try to hold out a little
bit longer to get more to get a first
this year
maybe a third this year or future pics
so that they can really stock up this
rebuild it steamed already has two
first-round selections right they
already have nine and they have 20
overall so another first round pick puts
them in in pretty special territory
where they could because we've seen I
mean they've gotten rid of clays
Campbell Jalen Ramsay AJ Bowie I I can't
believe winner for nets on the roster at
this point and now you have Yannick
egaku a who I do think will get moved
before the draft or during the draft on
April 23rd but that asking price is
going to be pretty significant yeah I
mean he's definitely voice today tweeted
yesterday about how he wants out and how
his time there in Jacksonville is just
done he's not making the market any
stronger for himself I can tell you that
but maybe he can't force his way out I
hate it for players so we get trapped in
the situation where you know the team
wants to move on you know that you want
to move on but you're just stuck you're
stuck in limbo you don't have any trades
going through it sucks for him hopefully
a deal gets done soon but I would not be
surprised if this thing drags out until
draft night well when you look across
the board of players that have been
openly disgruntled get their way in the
NFL it seems like we just saw Stefon
Diggs moved this happens a lot now and
it's something that Trent Williams agent
had said through a statement that you
know Trent Williams is the guy that's
doing this the right way he's been very
very quiet now he's fed up and feels
like because he did it the right way he
didn't get what he wanted I think in Gok
way he has seen both sides of this and
that's why he's been very vocal on
Twitter for quite some time right now
well and it worked the Jalen Ramsey you
know it you have an example he works in
your own organization where that works
you know I mean no one wants to go full
Antonio Brown but it it got him out of
Pittsburgh and he was the first one
really to use almost like an NBA player
type platform to say I don't want to
play her anymore and you know you that
stuff definitely has happened behind
closed doors but has never been on
social media and so I think with within
Gok way I do think he will get moved
because that reason now I think we're
like to Connors original pointless I
actually believe the Jacksonville could
be hurting their value by holding on to
him because you're gonna reach a point
of no return where you have I mean by
the end of day one in the draft if
you're still holding on to this player
you
already kicked your return on investment
a year down the road at this point so
there's gonna be pressure on
Jacksonville to get a deal done which is
why I think Mike careful is probably
poking that bear today this probably
been you know he's been you know told
something from sources to do that to to
re-up this because the longer the
Jacksonville holds on to inoculate I
would think his value only goes down
because he's not reporting under that
franchise tag guys there's no way in
hell he's gonna show up so it's like
trade him now or you're running the risk
of really really devaluing this player
yeah I mean it's like Josh Rosen last
year they were they held on to him for a
very long time even after they had
already drafted another quarterback i if
Jacksonville sitting there you know and
they've already drafted another edge
rusher like a chase on or the guy that I
forgot to mention on Monday eater gross
meadows I I think the value just
decreases and then you don't see the
return on investment that you're wanting
for a guy like Yannick and Gok way
because teams no hope you already
drafted his replacement he's not coming
back we'll give you a third-round pick
for it yeah the one thing I will say is
this being a weak edge class after chase
young and depending you know what teams
are valuing Kayla manches on from day
one and somebody like Rose Matos it
should help them you would think you
would think there's a Frank Clark trade
out on the table there yep I mean you
look at what the Chiefs gave up last
year I feels like that's comparable for
a guy like Hancock way because let's be
real guys he is probably gonna get
twenty million dollars a year because of
his age how good of a player he is so I
think it goes both ways but I'm with
both of you that Jacksonville you know
should really look to get this done by
the end of April if you're Baltimore I
don't you don't you at least call I mean
your pick I'd be in the first round it
might be it absolutely could be a money
thing but like in terms of just like
scheme fit I think Baltimore get it
Seattle like you see I don't know
someone drowning oh yeah I mean there
are so many different things you could
do here but we need to talk about when
you talk about money okay the Dolphins
could do it but I don't know that the
Jags are gonna trade with with the
Dolphins and then the Jets could do it
but do they they're not
eleven for him here too many other days
right now to second round picks I don't
think that alone is enough to get in Gok
way though no you'd have to start
looking into future picks you know
exactly Melo that's exactly it is that
teams and will Jacksonville you know
where do they feel they are right now
with their team do they feel like they
need to get picks this year because
there might be some people there that
feel like they're on the hot seat right
now so these are the politics that play
in the trades and what ultimately always
hurts the player at the end of it yeah
absolutely it is gonna be fascinating to
see what happens when Gok what happens
to Trent Williams does he end up a brown
does he end up a jet does he end up a
patriot there's been a lot of
speculation that he could wind up
somewhere outside of the NFC East we
guys let's take a break when we come
back we're gonna give you our fantasy
rookie picks for the 2020 season and
then Hunter Bryant tied in from
Washington joins the show all right
let's take a look at some of the top
rookies as far as fantasy football goes
we are about three weeks from the NFL
Draft and Melo got in here first I'll
just go ahead and say that but also I've
looked at this from a for 2020 not like
a dynasty where you're gonna draft this
guy and have them for the rest of your
career you guys may have done it a
little bit differently that's okay there
were no rules on this thing so at
quarterback I went with Justin Herbert
because I believe outside of Joe burrow
he is most likely to be the start a
starting quarterback out of this rookie
class Jordan loves a deaf guy to a
depending on where he goes now healthy
he has might not start right away
not a Jacob Eason fan not sure Jalen
hurt starts this year so that's where I
went at quarterback running back I
somehow stole G Andre Swift and I'm very
very happy about this I think what he
will bring to the table as a runner and
receiver makes him very valuable from a
fantasy football perspective I would
think no matter where you stand on
Jonathan Taylor or the other running
backs in this class from a fantasy
perspective I would think John Drake
Swift is the the no-brainer RB one out
wide receiver Melo stole Jerry Judy
because he hates me
so I tell you Henry drugs I think rugs
will definitely give you if it's a PPR
League you're probably eating lamb but
if you're just going yards and
touchdowns
I think rugs is gonna be very very
productive in that role tight end I want
khoka met again this is not a great
tight end class so
fit is gonna matter a lot for these guys
have commit goes to like the Bears in
round two I would love the opportunity
to change this pic because the Bears are
not gonna throw the ball very well and
then my Flex position I will with a
little bit of a sleeper here not a first
round named Darren Evans from appstate I
think he'll be a third round pick I love
his speed I think he's a very good
receiver out of the backfield so if
you're looking for like an Austin Eckler
type back Evans is my dude and I like
you said I got in here first
I took jobber I think that's the
no-brainer when you look at fantasy
needs and what's gonna happen here he's
gonna start day one he's gonna be with
the Bengals he's gonna be with AJ Green
he's gonna be with Joe Mixon they're
getting Jonah Williams back on the
offensive line it should be a good setup
he's walking into a good situation
they're in Cincinnati which is not
something Bengals fans have heard in a
very long time but I think that Joe
burrow if for some reason you needed to
take a quarterback and there was a
rookie in fantasy football
Joe burrow I think has to be the guy and
for Jonathan Taylor the reason I didn't
go with DeAndre swift here is because I
think that DeAndre swift is actually
running back that it's gonna have to be
paired with another back for a while
that's why when we did our fantasy dress
our mock draft so many drafts going on I
took him with the Falcons because I
think pairing him with a back is gonna
be good for him in those first couple
years he did it in Georgia he's not to
bail carry kau back that's gonna carry
the ball 20-plus times in a game he just
hasn't done that yet Jonathan Taylor is
Jonathan Taylor can come into any
organization any scheme right now carry
the ball 20-plus times a game and be
productive I think he's gonna be the
most productive running back as far as
rookies go wide receiver Jerry Judy I
actually I was trying to be nice and I
didn't take my number-one guy here I
took Jerry Judy I would have taken CD
lamb but I think that Jerry Judy can
come in and depending on the situation
that he lands in could be a Pro Bowl guy
his rookie year I really think that he's
gonna have very good production he's
gonna get open
he can run routes he's got good saw
hands I know he dropped some passes late
in the year this guy can he's got good
hands he can run he can do everything
Jerry Judy's a picket receiver for me at
tight in not a good tiding class I
almost want to Adam Troutman here but
I'm gonna go with Alberto the big target
ran a four four at the Ford in the 40 I
think that he can be productive I think
that he can learn to block and be that
in line tied in so if you're making me
take it tight in here Alberto is gonna
be one that I target and for the Flex
position I'm going Antonio Gibson I
don't know what position this guy's
gonna play out of Memphis I think that
he could be really good at running back
I don't know if he even wants to play
running back but I know that he can come
in and play the slot receiver and if
you're in a PPR League you're gonna get
some receptions from him you're probably
going to get some rushing yards hell you
might get some return yardage from him I
think he's a do-it-all guy who really
doesn't have a solid position yet but
that doesn't matter when you're looking
at fantasy when you have this Flex Flex
position available
how does Memphis always have that guy
day always I was looking back at their
depth from like 2018 they had the two
guys last year Henderson and Pollard
they had the freshman now ke gain well
they had Patrick Taylor who's going to
be drafted this year and they had
Antonio Gibson all on one team five
running back so they're going to be
drafted pretty high all on the same time
under Norvell got a job exactly yeah
when you have that stable of RAM
actually that rivals what Georgia and
Alabama have had over the years
absolutely and that's how you end up
having to put a guy like Gibson at wide
receiver who I do believe said he feels
very comfortable at running back I
thought he said that the Senior Bowl so
I like that pick a lot what an athlete
he is in the running back film there's
not a lot of it but it's really good
when you get through it alright let's
start here quarterback I went with two I
know he's not gonna be your full season
guy is not gonna be ready to go I see
two as a draft and stache kind of guy
we're down the stretch in the playoffs
he's probably gonna be playing
whoever drafts him they're gonna take a
look at him and I could see two of
coming in and just lighting it up for
that couple weeks that hopefully he's
you know fully back and healthy I love
what - it could do from day one second
here running back this is the one that
to me can really light the fantasy world
on fire it's Clyde Edwards elay er
because guys I look at his draft
projection and it seems to be the middle
of round two Texans Bucs Steelers he can
get rb1 kind of volume being picked by
one of those teams whether it's I mean
the Bucs have rose oh but still there's
touches there for Edwards II layer the
Steelers we know if he goes there he'll
be an absolute workhorse and once again
/ already back with contact balance that
can also catch the football
all right wide receiver CD lamb
no-brainer Melo thank you for not taking
him I think it's just when you look at
it he's somebody that's gonna get an
insane amount of targets he catches the
ball really well and he makes things
happens that happen after the catch the
most important thing with CD lamb in
terms of fantasy is he is so reliable in
the red zone where I think he's a 10
touchdown guy from day one when he comes
into the NFL tight in here I cheated I
went with chase Claypool yeah because
listen Cole commits went to Matt Alberto
went to Melo I don't like this tight end
class at all really after that maybe
Devon sese from UCLA is somebody that
kind of has a good rookie season but
overall there's no one coming in and
lighting it up as a pass catcher maybe
the guy that is coming on our show today
Hunter Bryant is someone that could do
that but I look at Claypool his size
profile the way he plays his mismatched
athleticism for the seam he should play
move tight end at the next level it's a
no-brainer to me in my eyes flex here I
went with another wide receiver and
that's Michael Pittman just because I
think he can win with deep speed but
he's a really good possession guy top
five hands in this draft for Michael
Pittman and once again I think he's a
player that he's not gonna be drafted
and a team that you know needs a number
one wide receiver where he's gonna see
the number one corner or double coverage
it feels like he'll be the number two or
number three guy in an already
established offense where the targets
could come to him kind of like we saw
earlier with Chris Godwin in Tampa Bay
yeah like it Connors got a big team
there man thick player where the bat is
the basketball team besides our
quarterback right yeah right yeah he's a
good point guard you know he's a
distributor I like to spot with Clyde
Edwards on that roster right that's
right drafted all fantasy basketball
team right that's not a bad way to build
a team right let's take a break we come
back we'll get that guy you were talking
about Hunter Bryant coming on the show
to talk about a little bit of a hype
video he's gonna be posting Wednesday
morning when you're listening to stick
to football
another great prospect interview here on
stick to football we have I think the
most athletic tied into the 2020 class
someone who's to be a matchup nightmare
that's hunter Bryant from the University
of Washington Hunter thank you for
waking up early there in the Pacific
time zone to come on with this man
yeah of course thank you for having now
one thing I want to ask you about we are
actually gonna be releasing you you are
and then we're gonna tweet it out as
well a little bit of a hype video on
Wednesday morning that's just gonna
remind teams and fans of those teams the
type of athlete the type of playmaker
that you are what kind of went into you
guys decision to do this I really was on
my agent he just hit me it say he saw me
make a little video so I was with it
really I got a lot like 10 so we just
went out hoop for a little bit just had
fun with everything he got back on the
clothes anyway whatever he started it it
you play a lot of basketball is there's
something about you playing with
Washington basketball team is that true
yes I'd always a kid with other Hooper
is on the team just hang out then kid
with them especially my freshman I was
two point and I mean yeah you drew a
great connection with the team Hunter
obviously the nation has kind of been
shut down mode right now how has that
changed you know your ability to train
and just get ready for the draft overall
day-to-day yeah I mean really hasn't
changed anything for me I got so do the
same things every day I go to Montana
work out and get treatment and the
leaders do some PT and a really that's
just on day to day what has it been like
trying to communicate with teams I know
a lot of that's gonna go through your
agent but you know I'm sure you're you
know you're gonna do this interview with
us then you're gonna have to FaceTime or
Skype with coaches and general managers
how has that been for you just trying to
manage your schedule yeah I mean this is
really a different layout I'm not really
used to doing a lot of FaceTime
interview like really important but on
yes that's just kind of some I gotta get
used to really and Mia being here like
doing everything over the phone issues
on those weird for me so I'm more of
like a physical person you for me
and I like being there like in price and
I'm in conversation so it's just a
different way out I got to get used to
it and I think I'm doing pretty good
are you throwing the suit-and-tie on for
the first time so you go a t-shirt oh no
I for sure will
right on our John be disrespectful and
there you go so have you had a lot of
team meetings so far I know it's a
little weird with the draft process how
it's working out this year but have you
had a chance to talk to a lot of teams
so far yeah I've talked to a good amount
of thing is really I think I talked
about can at this point I'm sure that
the whole month ago before the dress
we're gonna see really where how
everything flows hunter I know on the
depth chart you're listed at tied in but
it feels like you're just an offensive
weapon you play receiver you play tight
end in line move tight end what if teams
really been asking you to do at the next
level or do you have a preference of
what you like to do um really I like
doing everything that goes on is I could
do something that the coach likes to get
me on the field like regardless of what
it is and I think that's what kind of
other teams hitting me up or like really
talking about they all want different
which i think is really cool and unique
but yeah just talking to them like
seeing how some want me in the back sort
of that kind of had full bags and coming
out the bottom routes some yeah one
meals like the inline like as the guy
that could be both block in the past
catching some really just one minute I
could receiving and so coming in all
those different aspects of the game I'm
just having fun with everything I'm
excited to see where I'm gonna end up or
what my role is that something you're
comfortable with doing a little bit of
everything like that Connor said you
were asking a lot of Washington yeah
definitely definitely
I'm definitely feel like I'm really
comfortable just on the football field
like that's where that's where I find
the most comfort in life honestly issues
on the field and so anything that want
me to do it as gonna do like I feel like
I'm able to do it and I felt I'm
versatile enough to be able to line up
anyway
how long was it what about your favorite
sport like you talking about football a
lot we opened with basketball is
football the number one sport or is it
basketball not footballs always been the
number one split but on basketball just
growing up I had a lot of fun with it
and I we had the part to shoot and hoop
in and that's how it's been a lot of my
life free time and I feel like training
and just be hoping in the same state but
I mean I fell in love with basketball
football
or how pissed were you in the
SuperSonics left you're from Washington
right they don't want army lucky
breaking up how pissed were you in the
Sonics left Seattle because you're from
Washington right hello hey we've still
got a hundred hunter what was that
adjustment like going from Jake browning
to catching Jacob Easons fastball yeah
it was definitely a little bit of a
difference I bet different players those
very early players have a lot of respect
for both of them he is on the Ethan has
is is incredible really letting him do
some things that a quarterback at
quarterback that I've never seen in my
life but yeah his fastball it comes it
comes with some heat for sure so I'm
just getting acclimated that I'm
especially I'm I am breaking her out so
many digs or slants I was like a big
adjustment period I think for everyone
so I should I just do fall camp and all
that but I mean once you get used to I
feel like it's not that bad at all we
had some of the Georgia guys say he has
the strongest arm they've ever seen and
he was a freshman there yeah 100%
everything like that am i right in
saying how the whole like the whole
world's obviously they flipped upside
down right now
what was your draft weekend plan before
everybody got told to stay at home and
what is your draft weekend plan now um I
didn't really have a plan to be honest
with you last weekend I think now it's
really just have like a little
get-together like some family and
franchise over just relax and then wait
for the car we can do it's probably
gonna suck I mean usually you see the
pea to the room and you have the whole
family over now you're gonna have to
limit it what's it gonna take to get me
on that guest list
I'm not gonna put you on good luck get
in there Mel yeah arriving to Washington
right now
Hunter is there anything anything crazy
teams asked you during meetings
obviously you got to go to the combine
before all this shut down all the pro
days and things like that what were
those interviews like because I feel
like the FaceTime interviews are
probably a little bit more lighthearted
while everyone tells us the combine
interviews are very intense yeah
honestly I don't even think the combine
interviews for that insane I really we
just sat down they asked me like a
little bit of background about myself
and then we just talked well we turn on
some film and I'm just telling my rules
of the plays or what we were doing a
well and so really most of my interviews
which is talking football I think
they're just trying to like test my
football IQ I really get it read into
that because I'm a junior coming out and
cuz I'm young and they don't know a lot
about you and so yeah I mean I didn't
really have a problem with interviews I
don't got no crazy questions I've heard
stories about guys crazy questions I
never done one what was your thought
when coach Peterson retired it had you
guys seen it coming or was this just a
complete shock to everyone
yeah I think anybody saw her come here
honestly I mean we just got a text after
the Apple cut that we had a team meeting
at the next morning or a couple of days
after and we all went in I know what it
was gonna be we thought about that we
thought it was about the bull game
honestly and then Pete came in and told
I said he was gonna step down and that
Lake was definite everybody was just
gonna shot I we had some players time
like the staff was solid nobody saw
coming at all but honestly I think was
late on the programs headed in a really
good direction I think he's just a
competitor hurt and he can't do a lot of
great thing to pedicles position did
coach Peterson leaving have anything to
do their way into your decision to leave
early for the draft
no honestly it didn't I think I was
arguing already has a decision at that
point that I was gonna leave I knew what
I was just really he made the
announcement after the season already
ended after the regular season ended and
so at that point I already knew that I
wanted to come out and I was playing and
so I didn't have any effect on him but
it was definitely a big surprise do you
think that transition though is a smooth
one I know you just reference that you
know obviously Peterson retired shock
people people are mo
but going to lake did that always feel
like a you know a no-brainer kind of
decision to transition to him yeah
definitely I mean I think if you watch
them on the sidelines during games even
during practice and just see how focused
how much of competitor how locked-in he
is how to tell you I mean it was really
a no-brainer to have him step up as a
head coach especially like hiring
in-house like you're not bringing in
someone new you're not changing the
closer that we had like everything is
more or less staying the same just I
think a little bit more competition just
within the team I mean yeah as far as
the next level for you coming out of
Washington we talked about how you're
kind of a utility knife on offense is
there a guy in the NFL that you've
watched it said okay that's that's the
type of player I'm gonna be yeah we
really are
I want to be my own player honestly but
I think I watched a lot of Delanie
Walker everything they're kind of both
of those guys because they're they're
both about my size I've been both around
6-2 6-3 like 240 250 looking between
them and they're both extremely
productive at the tight end position
I think Delaney does a really great job
I'm blocking anticipation
he's overall great three down side in
and that heavy engrams just explosive
especially with the ball in his hands
that's not to not take a lot of Friday
and she's trying to make plays on my
feet after the kiss and I think he does
a great publication so really I watch
both then kind of see how they're able
to be productive in the league and what
I can do I emulate that well I think you
just help me write a scouting report on
yourself so help me out a little bit
more because I have to write someone
you're your teammates so give me a
little rundown a guy like Jake Eason and
the running back you have there and
Ahmed yeah I mean well Ethan I
definitely think is that Sean his arm in
the dress um I think he threw the
hardest and a little speed thing they
did at the fastball thing at the combine
thinking here like 62 miles four hours
and crazy [ __ ] like that but now he says
playmaker
I mean he can do a lot of things with
his arm no one's ever too deep down the
field for him to get it to you and I
mean really he just wins games
and then Sevan I'm not honestly I think
that's one of the most explosive back
I think I'd see if you watch this film
to see we did on the field he could turn
any run it's a house car really
especially like his game speed and so I
think having him hey I heard offenses me
was extremely fun this year and if you
tried a lot of fun with all the athletes
yeah and not that but gonna be great
place the last one I got for you just
going back to your practices i watch
miles bryant play I actually got to come
out to the west coast this year when you
guys played USC and when I watched miles
Bryant pet play I mean this is the
feistiest small corner I have ever seen
does he bring it like that and practice
too when he's covering you guys a
hundred percent me and him would go
edited practice never got to see that
just body around not he's strong but
he's strong it was over his balance is
some of the best I've ever seen you out
of any athlete in my life and this is
change the direction makes them
especially unique play and that that
sides to like you don't really expect
that coming out of him but like when you
really go up against him like every play
like every practice it just turns into a
competition like every rep you gotta go
try to win that this is that's a
competitor too and we definitely got
each other a lot better I think
throughout both of our time he did and
so now that he can do a lot of different
things on the food I think it's pretty
cool to see like I think glass he was
playing nickel this year he's playing
safety was very versatile too sonar
that's I had big road and I'm excited if
he's gonna do awesome hundred man thank
you again for your time and good luck
like you said we got a about three weeks
to go so you're gonna be a busy dude
with a lot of face time calls from these
GM's but it try to enjoy this very
unique process and we'll be rooting for
you man wherever you end up I thank you
I really appreciate it thanks honor good
luck man thank you